c'est une compagnie pour moi qu'est-ce
que vous voulez que je fasse j'ai pas ça
faut quelque chose pour me distraire
oui et ben voyez elle me cause puis vous
avez votre mari ah ben voilà je l'ai
malheureusement que je l'aurais pas tout
le temps il viendra un jour qu'il faudra
se séparer et oui je suis mariée le 23
mai 1914 h il y a 23 ans que 63 ans que
je suis avec c'est une belle vie vous
savez c'est long hein oh
c'est on a des petits mots temps en
temps on se dispute mais ça
revient ce n'est pas bien grave pendant
la guerre j'ai été en Italie j'ai été en
Bulgarie en Serbie vous connaissez tout
ça vous madame tout le temps il casse la
tête avec ça tout le temps qu' voit du
monde allez le voil avec ta Guer de 14
ohi il me casse les pieds quand quand il
cause de ça